a few years ago I got a message from an
ex and it said roses are red violets are
blue
I've got chlamydia and you might have to
which first of all is genius but it
meant I was taking a trip down to the
clinic the next morning to get tested I
have a point to the story and I swear
it's about computers if you ever want to
see a complete cross section of London
life do join the queue of the STI
testing clinic first thing in the
morning actually get yourself tested
anyways it's the right thing to do
anyway
I go to the clinic I pee in the sample
tube i seal it up I hand it over and
they give me a little business card with
a phone number and a passcode on it and
I can call that number the next day and
if my tests are all clear then the
system will tell me and if they're not
it will pass me over to someone at the
clinic because you do not deliver bad
news with an automated system so the
next day I call the number type in the
code and the system says thanks here are
your test results then there is a pause
a proper ten-second long pause and as I
stood there on my mobile in the middle
of the street it felt a little bit like
that artificial pause they add in
reality shows before they announce the
winner it felt like there was a
spotlight on me there was all dramatic
tension music playing in the background
and then it says we're putting you
through to one of our team please stand
by
that's bad news right bad news comes
from a human why they passing me through
someone picks up and give them a
passcode again and they say now it's all
clear you don't need to worry
everything's negative you you're fine
and I asked why the system put me
through and they say no idea just does
that sometimes it just does that
sometimes
did the database lookup fail in the
background and it dealt with a timeout
by just passing me to a human was there
a small note on my file somewhere that
confused it I have no idea they had no
idea because whoever wrote that code
whoever designed that system the moment
there was any error they just told to go
to we're putting you through without
explaining why and without thinking what
that might cause that phone system is
used by people asking about things way
more serious than chlamydia the sort of
things that you can't cure with a course
of antibiotics
and sure on the scale of complaints it
is minor but mistakes like that are a
symptom of something much bigger I've
talked about bodging things in the past
I encourage it for Hobby projects just
slapping something together as a
proof-of-concept just so it works for
you is a great principle when you are
making a thing for yourself but if
you're making something for the public
for mass consumption particularly
something that is going to be used by
people in very vulnerable moments then
you've got to take a lot more every time
we build something for the public we
have to start making a trade-off how
much time and money is it worth to deal
with every edge case maybe the design
thought that lookups would only fail one
a million times and if that's the case
then yes it's probably not reasonable to
bother recording a whole extra message
and programming in a whole extra edge
case but if the lookup fails often
enough that the clinic receptionist just
dismisses it as normal well by that
point it's too late to make the change
isn't it the systems in place it'd be
far too expensive to fix it now it'll do
the trouble is that we're often dealing
with unknown harms and unintended
consequences far too often a bodge
together system that was just meant to
be a test gets rolled out into
production and everyone just has to deal
with the bugs because that's all anyone
can afford to do I will always bet on
incompetence rather than malice I will
always bet on someone just not thinking
about consequences rather than thinking
of them and going yes who cares we see
this with big tech companies Facebook
allows the world to communicate in
unprecedented ways it does huge amounts
of emotional labor for us it allows
people to keep in touch with old friends
that they would just fall away from
otherwise but it's also enabled stalkers
and abusers to reach people they
shouldn't it's allowed a huge amount of
private data to be misused without real
consent and it's arguably helped cause
terrifying election meddling now I don't
believe anyone in Facebook's management
was rubbing their hands in delight at
that chaos it was causing it's just a
series of seemingly reasonable decisions
that added up to huge consequences and
then there's YouTube it allows anyone to
publish their experiences to the war
it provides income for creative people
that bypasses traditional media and it's
helped people connect with other
people's lives it's also helped to
radicalize folks to promote conspiracy
theories and to traumatize children are
those trade-offs worth it depends on
your moral framework and it depends
let's be honest on how it's affected you
personally it's not like there's a
crystal ball that will tell you yes
you're brand new dating app you're
developing that will cause 1,000 couples
to marry and live happily ever after but
it will also get three people murdered
the real world is not a trophy problem
the STI result system that I called
presumably reduced the workload on staff
and it allowed people to check the
results out of hours when it was
convenient and discreet for them you
would hope that something like that
wouldn't have a downside but then the
designers screwed it up because they
thought it was good enough and it wasn't
one extra check one extra voice message
that said sorry I can't find your result
just a moment would have solved that
every time that we design a system we
have to minimize the potential of harm
look at the code you write look at the
systems you design and think how could
this reviews how could this fall apart
what are the failure states here if you
were a bad actor if you wanted to use
this maliciously how would you go about
it think about how you'd attack your own
systems explore those failure States
deliberately screw things up and see how
your code copes because if you don't
somewhere else will thank you very much
to the Center for computing history at
Cambridge who let me film with all their
old equipment and to all my proofreading
team who've checked in my script